[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend der Weltfußball trauert um Pelé
dazu kommen wir noch später in der
Sendung blicken aber zuerst in die
Ukraine dort beginnt in diesen Tagen
normalerweise die Vorbereitung auf die
Neujahrsfeiern die als Familienfest
ähnlich bedeutend sind wie Weihnachten
doch in diesen Kriegszeiten heißt das
stattdessen stundenlanger Luftalarm
Schutz suchen Angst tot und Zerstörung
angesichts einer erneuten massiven
Angriffswelle mit mehr als 60 Raketen
die über verschiedenen Teilen des Landes
abgefeuert wurden und auch wenn die
ukrainische Flugabwehr viele Orts das
Schlimmste wohl verhindern konnte die
Folgen sind dennoch grausam alle Brühe
berichtet aus der Ukraine
so hört sich Krieg an Explosionen am
Morgen in Kiew
16 russische Raketen nehmen Ziel auf die
Hauptstadt alle werden von der
ukrainischen Flugabwehr abgeschossen
wieder einmal suchen die Menschen Schutz
in der U-Bahn warten auf das Ende des
luftalarms in Kiew im ganzen Land ist
das trauriger Alltag
unser Leben wir wissen nicht wie lange
der Krieg dauern wird es ist schwer
jeden Tag Angst zu haben und das Leben
auf später zu vertagen
russische Raketen abgefangen was das
heißt sehen wir in einem Vorort von Kiew
Trümmer sind herabgestürzt haben mehrere
Häuser zerstört drei Menschen wurden
verletzt
Tatjana was sie livnas Tochter und ihre
Enkelin werden im Krankenhaus behandelt
sie hatte große Angst sie hat so ins
Telefon geschrieben dass ich nicht
einmal verstehen konnte was hier
passiert ist
rettungskräfte sind vor Ort Räumen den
Schritt beiseite am Rand stehen
traumatisierte Anwohner die einfach nur
Glück hatten
ich wohne hier in der Nähe und ja ich
habe das gehört wie die Rakete
explodierte mein Mann und ich saßen in
der Küche wir sind Gott sei Dank
unverletzt stehen aber unter Schock
chemisches
Gesetze es gab eine sehr starke
Explosion bei uns wurden Fenster und
Türen aufgedrückt wir wurden an die Wand
geschleudert
im Zentrum von Kiew gibt es keine
direkten Schäden aber auch hier wird es
immer schwerer so etwas wie Normalität
aufrecht zu erhalten dessen ist sich
auch der Bürgermeister bewusst unsere
kritische Infrastruktur sehr beschädigt
deswegen ist äh eine defizierte Energie
haben wir in unsere Stadt heute jetzt im
Moment wir haben 40 %. unsere Anwohner
ohne Elektrizität mit Blick aufs Neue
Jahr und auf die Wochen die vorkehr
Fliegen wie schwer wird das alles hier
ist kein Geheimnis der Russen wollen uns
erfrieren lassen ohne Heizung ohne
Wasser wie kontrollieren die ganze
Situation aber trotzdem ist
wir war schon ein paar mal sehr nah zum
sogenannte Blackout
bedrückende Aussichten für Kiew am Ende
dieses ersten Kriegsjahres
das russische Verteidigungsministerium
prahlt mit den heutigen Angriffen die
kalibre würden niemals ausgehen damit
sind russische Mittelstrecken Raketen
gemeint mit denen die Ukraine heute
beschlossen wurde ob das so stimmt dass
man davon ein schier unerschöpfliches
Arsenal habe steht auf einem anderen
Blatt in jedem Fall sind es sehr teure
Raketen von denen nach ukrainischen
Angaben viele abgewehrt werden bevor sie
ihr Ziel erreichen der russische
Außenminister lavrov hat derweil noch
mal betont russland werde besetzte
Gebiete nicht aufgeben und über solche
Bedingungen auch nicht verhandeln doch
wird diese demonstrative
Entschlossenheit von der russischen
Bevölkerung geteilt Christian Siem
zeichnet einen Stimmungsbild in Moskau
moskau ist berühmt für seine Glitzerwelt
kurz vor Neuer und Weihnachten
willkommene Ablenkung in diesem düsteren
Tagen das in diesem Jahr etwas anders
ist sieht man nicht nur am leuchtenden
Set das Symbol der russischen
Militäroperation als Dekoelement aber
die Weihnachtsstimmung gedämpft lange
versuchten die Menschen hier das was in
der Ukraine passiert zu ignorieren doch
das änderte sich schlagartig Ende
September als Putin die Teil mobil
machen verkündete und hunderttausende
zum Kampf an die Front schickte
meine Verwandten sind davon betroffen
wir hoffen also dass alles gut wird das
Frieden herrscht
ich finde dass die Bürger Russlands mich
eingeschlossen nicht das moralische
Recht haben zu äußern was sie bewegt
wenn Menschen so leiden müssen
Kritik hören wir hier nicht besinnlich
soll es trotz allem werden so wie bei
Familie varushin in Moskau soll das
zusammen sein an den Feiertagen Halt
geben in einer Zeit in denen vielen
nicht mehr viel bleibt außer dem Rückzug
ins Private der kleine Timur spielt
ukrainische Lieder
die mag ich sagte achtjährige in seinem
Leben spielt die Feindschaft zum
Nachbarland keine Rolle aber Mutter Lena
macht sich Sorgen auch um die Zukunft
ihres Sohnes sie fühlt sich ohnmächtig
wie so viele
wir Russen sind jetzt die geächteten als
ob alle die hier leben Terroristen wären
so werden Russen jetzt behandelt aber
russische Bürger sind nicht
gleichzusetzen mit der russischen
Politik weil wir nicht für diese Aktion
unser Regierung gestimmt haben
[Musik]
Freiheit für die politischen Gefangenen
ruft Studentin Julia petrowa vor drei
Wochen gerade wurde im Gericht hinter
ihr der oppositionelle Ilja Yashin zu
achteinhalb Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt
wir treffen Julia ein paar Tage später
wieder vor dem bolsche Theater gekleidet
hat sich die 20-Jährige in den Farben
der Ukraine auf ihren Händen steht
stoppt den Krieg sie weiß dass sie dafür
bestraft werden kann
es gibt ein Sprichwort vor dem
Bettelsack und dem Gefängnis ist niemand
sicher in Russland hat dieses Sprichwort
einen neuen Sinn bekommen zur falschen
Zeit am falschen Ort für Aktionen kann
fast jeder hinter Gitter kommen oder
weil man bekannt ist wie ihr ja Yashin
da wird jedes Wort verfolgt man wartet
nur auf den richtigen Moment nicht
festzunehmen
genau das passiert kurz nach unserem
Interview mit ihr selbst Julia wird von
der spezialpolizei gestoppt mitgenommen
und verhört für sie beginnt das neue
Jahr mit einem Gerichtstermin der
Vorwurf Diskreditierung der russischen
Armee Julia droht eine Geldstrafe Kritik
ist im Russland von heute kaum noch
möglich und gefährlich das wird sich
wohl auch 2023 nicht ändern
dann schalten wir noch zu unseren
Korrespondenten in Kiew und in Moskau
fangen wir mal in Kiew an wie hast du
den Tag heute dort erlebt
am frühen Morgen gab es hier Luftalarm
die eigentlichen Angriffe begannen dann
kurz nach 8 Uhr morgens wir haben
heftige Explosionen gehört auch hier im
Zentrum von Kiew von hier oben konnten
wir dann sehen wie die ukrainische
Luftabwehr diese russischen Raketen
abgefangen hatte alle 16 die ja für Kiew
bestimmt waren und nach zweieinhalb
Stunden war der Alarm dann auch vorbei
trotzdem war das ja ein massiver Angriff
mal wieder auf das ganze Land auf die
Infrastruktur in hakif in Odessa in
levife wurde die Stromversorgung
unterbrochen und die Sorge ist schon
groß dass diese Angriffe auch in den
nächsten Tagen weitergehen könnten bis
er die letzten Wochen durch die Ukraine
gereist also eben nicht nur in Kiel wo
steht dieses Land am Ende dieses Jahres
nach 10 Monaten kriegt
unser erster Dreh auf dieser Reise das
war ein soldatenbegräbnis in der
Westukraine ein 29-jähriger der bei den
Kämpfen um bachmut getötet wurde und die
Menschen in seiner Heimatstadt die haben
auf sehr bewegende Weise von ihm
Abschied genommen und das kommt mir
irgendwie ein bisschen bezeichnen vor
für die Situation in der dieses Land ist
die unbedingt der Unterstützung für die
Soldaten auch der Wille dass dieser
Krieg hier gewonnen werden muss dass
dieser russische Angriffskrieg abgewehrt
wird das spüren wir immer wieder aber
dann fordert dieser Krieg natürlich auch
Opfer und nicht nur bei den Soldaten
sondern eben auch bei der
Zivilbevölkerung und gerade jetzt von
Neujahr diesen besonderen Fest hier in
der Ukraine da spüren viele dass Ihnen
möglicherweise auch noch schlimme Zeiten
bevorstehen
lecken wir nach Moskau auf die russische
Sicht auf zehn Monate Krieg gegen das
Nachbarland Christian
viele trauen sich vor der Kamera nicht
wirklich zu sagen was sie denken das
kann in deinem Bericht eben ja auch
deutlich zu Tage merkst du denn hinter
vorgehaltene Hand das ist da ein
geändertes Stimmungsbild gibt
ja tatsächlich haben wir viele versucht
nach dem Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine im Februar das ganze irgendwie
zu verdrängen und nicht wahrzunehmen so
nach dem Motto ja das ist alles weit weg
und das betrifft mich nicht und ähm ich
bin daran auch nicht beteiligt und es
hat sich dann wirklich schlagartig Ende
September geändert als Putin diese
teilmobilisierung verkündet hatten
plötzlich in jeder Familie die Frage
auftauchte sind wir jetzt doch von
diesem Konflikt betroffen muss
vielleicht ähm der Vater der Bruder der
Sohn oder der Onkel müssen die plötzlich
an die Front also da war es plötzlich
doch sehr im Bewusstsein der Menschen
angekommen und jetzt ähm nehmen wir hier
bei den Menschen ja eigentlich eher so
eine Art Ohnmacht waren Menschen wissen
nicht wirklich was Sie was Sie damit
anfangen können protestieren ist
schwierig die Sorge ist auch große ist
vielleicht doch eine weitere
Mobilisierung geben könnte und ich
glaube viele leben jetzt hier eher so
nach dem Motto abwarten und bloß nicht
auffallen und so zu protestieren wie wie
die junge Studentin Julia von der eben
berichtet hast dass das tun dann
wirklich nur sehr wenige
tatsächlich sieht man dass nur noch sehr
selten
julia hat das bewusst gemacht sie wusste
auch dass Sie mit diesen Aktionen sie
hat ja auch schon vor dem Bericht nach
Freiheit gerufen vor dem Gericht nach
Freiheit gerufen hat die Freiheit der
politischen Gefangenen gefordert sie
weiß dass das gefährlich ist und
trotzdem hat sie den Wunsch diese
Meinung so zu äußern aber wir sehen dass
in der Tat sehr selten es gab als die
Mobilisierung verkündet wurde gab es ja
noch mal Proteste die wurden brutal
niedergeschlagen jetzt wenn man Kritik
hört kommt das von Russland und Russen
die das Land bereits verlassen haben und
im Ausland sind was er übersehen das ist
immer neue schärfere Gesetze gibt neue
Sicherheitsgesetze zum Beispiel hat
Putin heute eingesetzt unterschrieben
das Sabotage noch mal ganz hart bestraft
und das soll natürlich die Menschen auch
einschüchtern und jeder wird sich dann
ganz genau überlegen ob er irgendeine
Aktion plant denn die Gesetze sind hier
oft sehr schwammig formuliert dass man
dann nicht wirklich weiß ob man davon
vielleicht betroffen ist oder nicht
Dankeschön nach Moskau nach Kiew
es würde für Vladimir Putin sehr in die
Hände spielen wenn zwischen seinen
Freunden in Serbien und den benachbarten
Kosovo ein neuer Balkan-Krieg Ausbrechen
der Europäer und NATO dann in Atem
hielte mit dem Thema geht es jetzt bei
dir weiter Hanna ja im neu aufgeflammten
Konflikt zwischen Serbien und dem Kosovo
gibt es allerdings erste Zeichen der
Entspannung die kosovarische Regierung
hat ihren größten Grenzübergang zu
Serbien wieder geöffnet zuvor hatte der
serbische Präsident Vucic die erhöhte
Alarmbereitschaft für Militär und
Polizei aufgehoben und zudem den Abbau
der von Serben errichteten Barrikaden im
Kosovo angekündigt wie diese Bilder
zeigen wurde damit bereits begonnen
Hintergrund der Spannungen ist ein
Konflikt um die Unabhängigkeit des
Kosovos das früher zu Serbien gehört
hatte
trotz der massiven corona-welle in China
die Deutschland keinen Anlass für neue
einreisebeschränkungen das erklärte ein
Sprecher des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums die Lage
werde beobachtet doch bislang gebe es
keine Hinweise auf neue gefährlichere
Virusvarianten mehrere andere Länder
haben dagegen eine testpflicht für
Reisende aus China angekündigt darunter
die USA Italien Japan und Indien
ab Januar haben deutlich mehr Menschen
ein Recht auf Wohngeld doch Experten
warnen vor einem Stau bei der
Bearbeitung der Anträge also vor langen
Wartezeiten laut einer Untersuchung des
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft
treffen die vielen neuen Antragsteller
auf viel zu wenig Mitarbeiter in den
Ämtern dort würden hunderte Stellen
fehlen durch die wohngeldreform sind ab
2023 statt 600.000 voraussichtlich zwei
Millionen Haushalte wohngeldberechtigt
die Bezüge sollen sich durchschnittlich
fast verdopp
emeritierten Papst Benedikt dem 16 geht
es den Umständen entsprechend gut das
hat der Vatikan bekannt gegeben der
Zustand von Benedikt sei so wörtlich
ernst aber stabil auf den Petersplatz in
Rom kam auch heute wieder viele Gläubige
der amtierende Papst franziskus hatte
gestern gesagt Benedikt sei sehr krank
und zum Gebet für ihn aufgerufen
die italienische Regierung hat ein
Dekret verabschiedet dass die
Seenotrettung nach Ansicht von
Hilfsorganisationen erheblich erschweren
wird unter anderem müssen die Schiffe
künftig direkt nach einer Rettung einen
zugewiesenen Hafen ansteuern ohne
möglichen weiteren flüchtlingsboten in
der Nähe helfen zu dürfen aktuell ist
die Ocean Viking mit 113 geretteten auf
dem Weg ins 900 Kilometer entfernte
Ravenna auch hier werfen
Hilfsorganisationen der italienischen
Regierung vor Retter und Flüchtlinge mit
dieser langen Fahrt bewusst zu
schikanieren
in Jerusalem ist Benjamin netanjaro
heute zum Ministerpräsidenten vereidigt
worden ein Wiedergänger nach der
vorletzten Parlamentswahl als es
netanjau nicht gelungen war eine
Regierung zu bilden hatten seine
Kritiker gehofft sie seien ihn los zumal
Bibi wie in Israel genannt wird im
Mittelpunkt eines immer noch laufenden
korruptionsprozesses Stand bzw steht
aber jetzt ist er zurück mit Hilfe eines
Regierungsbündnisses das so rechtste
teils rechtsextremen und radikal
religiös ist wie noch nie zuvor eine
Regierung können Israel wo wird das
hinführen die Frage stellt man sich
nicht nur in Israel und den Namen Osten
Thomas Reichert
tausende demonstrieren heute vor dem
Parlament Bürgerrechtler lgbtq Veteranen
sogar ein ehemaliger
Verteidigungsminister unter netanjau
protestiert mit gegen dessen neuer
Regierung und auch Religion ist dabei
ehemaliger General der Luftwaffe ein
Kriegsfeld in Israel
die Politik dieser Regierung
widerspricht fast allem woran wir
glauben der Demokratie dem Liberalismus
und den jüdischen Werten
benjamin netanjau ist zurück an der
Macht und gibt dafür Nationalisten und
Ultraorthodoxen so viel ab davon wie nie
zuvor in Israel Geschichte
schwach schwach ruft deshalb die
Opposition und netanjau wehrt sich
wir werden die Vormachtstellung Israels
in der Region sicherstellen indem wir
ständig stärker werden
Religion fürchtet dass es genau
umgekehrt ist dass Israel sich gerade
selbst schwächt er war einer jener acht
jagdbomberpiloten die Anfang der 80er
Jahre in der Operation Opera den
Atomreaktor des Irak zerstörten
chefir als sein Leben riskiert für
dieses Land nun schrieb er einen offenen
Brief aus Sorge um die Demokratie über
1200 Veteran haben mit unterzeichnet
Piloten haben von uns immer erwartet
dass wir die ersten sind die losfliegen
und sich der Gefahr stellen wenn sie
sich abzeichnen
wir sollten etwas tun so wie damals als
wir jünger waren
sorgt sich um die Unabhängigkeit der
Justiz die netanjas Regierung
einschränken will und um dies
oberste Priorität für die neue Regierung
hat der Siedlungsausbau auch in den
Gebieten die Palästinenser für sich und
ihren künftigen Staat beanspruchen die
Siedlungspolitik sollen als Minister
anti-arabische Extremisten mitbestimmen
die arabischen Händler auf dem Markt bei
Jerusalems Damaskus Tor hoffen deshalb
dass die neue Regierung nicht lange
halten könnte doch es gibt auch dies die
Drohung auf Gewalt mit Gewalt zu
antworten
ich glaube dass wir auf eine sehr
schmerzhafte Zeit zusteuern nicht nur
für die Palästinenser sondern ich denke
auch dass dies Auswirkungen auf die
Sicherheit der Israelis haben wird nach
der Bestätigung im Parlament kommt
abends das Kabinett zum ersten Mal
zusammen und nettern ja auch versucht zu
beruhigen
für die Minderheit die Angst vor uns hat
sie brauchen keinen zu haben wir werden
nach dem Prinzipien Handeln an die die
Mehrheit der Israelis glaubt es ist Zeit
anzustoßen
währenddessen wird auf den Straßen immer
noch demonstriert die Angst vor dem was
mit dieser Regierung kommt sie bleibt
zu den dauert Themen für jede
israelische Regierung gehört die
Bedrohung Israels durch Iran auch und
der Hinsicht ist die tanjavu seit jeher
einen Hardliner der den damaligen
US-Präsidenten Trump daran bestärkte aus
dem atomabkommen mit Iran auszusteigen
inzwischen hat sich Iran mit seinen
Waffenlieferungen an Russland selbst so
weit ins Abseits gestellt das von einem
neuen atomabkommen derzeit sowieso kaum
mehr die Rede ist der Konflikt mit
Israel wiederum könnte sich weiter
verschärfen wenn Teheran glaubt damit
von seinen inländischen Dramen ablenken
zu können die Mullahs haben aus guten
Gründen Angst vor einer Revolution wo
steht das Land jetzt am Ende dieses
aufwühlenden Jahres
es ist zum verzweifeln fast täglich neue
Rekorde die keiner will Tiefstände bei
der iranischen Währung Höchststände bei
den Preisen die Menschen wie hier in
Teheran müssen sparen wenn Eier
plötzlich das dreifache kosten bleibt
kein Geld für Nagellack und Lippenstift
die Preise steigen der hohe Dollarkurs
schadet unserem Geschäft denn auch unser
Einkauf hängt vom Dollar ab die Kunden
kommen rein und fragen nach dem Preis
und kaufen nichts es ist zu teuer
geworden sie können es sich nicht mehr
leisten
wir machen große Verluste sowohl wegen
des steigenden Dollarkurses aber auch
wegen der Unsicherheit durch die
Proteste
die Regierung macht den Westen für die
Krise verantwortlich aber die Menschen
wissen die Krise ist hausgemacht auch
dass ein Grund für die große
Unzufriedenheit im Land Präsident raisi
vorgestern bei einer staatstrauerfeier
für gefallene im iranisch irakischen
Krieg vor 40 Jahren wieder sieht er die
Drahtzieher der monatelangen Unruhen im
Ausland
wir öffnen unsere Arme all denen die
verführt wurden ihr seid die Jugend
unseres Landes unsere Männer und Frauen
die Arme der Nation sind für jeden
geöffnet aber wir kennen keine Gnade
gegenüber unseren Feinden
das demonstriert das Regime im Tag für
Tag Tränengas bei der Trauerfeier für
den 19-Jährigen Hamit ruhy in Teheran
heute eine Mutter betrauert den Tod
ihres Sohnes in easy zwei von hunderten
Opfern bisher die Brutalität der
Staatsmacht erzeugt Wut aber auch
Ohnmacht und Angst statt
Großdemonstrationen auf den Straßen
Trauerfeiern und allabendliche
Protestrufe aus den Fenstern tot dem
Diktator rufen Sie doch Irans Führung
sitze so fest im Sattel wie vor Beginn
der Proteste meinte Iran Forschers heran
afajan weil viele das Regime ideologisch
stützten vor allem aber wirtschaftlich
gut von und mit ihm leben könnten da die
soziale Basis der Führung ist stärker
als viele denken vor allem aber sind die
Sicherheitskräfte stark sie haben selbst
eine erfolgreiche Revolution gemacht
wollen verhindern dass ihnen das gleiche
passiert und haben dafür alle
notwendigen Maßnahmen ergriffen
Gefahr drohe dem Regime nur aus den
eigenen Reihen analysiert affajan er
sieht einen Streit innerhalb der Führung
der Islamischen Republik über den
richtigen Kurs nachgiebig oder knallhart
in jedem Fall aber mit einem gemeinsamen
Ziel selbst an der Macht zu bleiben
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Hannah mit dem Blick auf die
deutsche Wirtschaft deutsche Unternehmen
genießen weltweit ja durchaus einen
guten Ruf doch geht es darum wie
wertvoll der börsennotierte Konzerne
sind ist Deutschland weit abgeschlagen
sehr weit sogar frag Wiedmann die Top
100 wird dominiert von den USA warum
schaffen es deutsche Unternehmen nicht
in die Nähe der Spitze es klingt hart
aber an der Börse zählen nicht die
Erfolge der Vergangenheit die
Kapitalmärkte bewerten
Zukunftsperspektiven Deutschland das
steht vor allem für Auto und
Maschinenbau das ist gut sehr gut sogar
dass wir dieses nur haben aber was ist
mit IT z.B mit künstlicher Intelligenz
es macht den Eindruck dass nicht alle
aber viele deutsche und europäische
Unternehmen da eher an der Seitenlinie
stehen das Spiel und damit die Regeln
für die digitale Wirtschaft insgesamt
die bestimmen asiatische und vor allem
amerikanische Unternehmen
jetzt haben wir aber gerade die großen
us-tech-konzerne wie Apple oder
Microsoft an der Börse zuletzt stark an
Wert verloren ja ihre Aktienkurse
verlieren in diesem Jahr sogar um über
25 Prozent und dennoch dominieren sie
das Ranking der wertvollsten Unternehmen
unter den Top Ten befindet sich mit dem
Öl Multi Saudi Aramco nur einen nicht
amerikanischer Konzern was uns einfach
zeigt wie weit die großen us-tech
Giganten den übrigen Konzernen bereits
entdeckt waren trotz Billionen Dollar
Wertverlust in diesem Jahr führen Sie
das Ranking immer noch an eines will ich
aber auch schon noch sagen nicht alles
lässt sich an den Börsenkursen ablesen
Deutschland hat viele mittelständische
Weltmarktführer die wenigsten von ihnen
sind an der Börse gelistet und vergessen
mir nicht Konzerne von Weltrang wie
Bosch Aldi oder Lidl sie alle haben in
den letzten Jahrzehnten am guten
rufdeutscherunternehmen mitgearbeitet
vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
2022 haben deutlich mehr Jugendliche zur
Zigarette gegriffen als im vergangenen
Jahr das ist das Ergebnis einer
aktuellen Studie der Universität
Düsseldorf demnach hat sich der Anteil
der rauchenden bei den 14 bis
17-Jährigen fast verdoppelt und liegt
jetzt bei 15,9 Prozent im Vorjahr waren
es noch 8,7 und auch bei den 18 bis
24-Jährigen stieg der Anteil von gut 36%
auf 40,8 seit Beginn der Erhebungen 2016
hat es noch nie so eine hohe
Raucherquote unter Jugendlichen gegeben
wie in diesem Jahr
zum Auftakt der Vierschanzentournee gab
es in Oberstdorf gute Platzierungen für
deutsche Springer und einen Sieger aus
Norwegen Halver graneryt war der mit
Abstand beste Springer des Tages und
verfehlte im ersten Durchgang den
Schanzenrekord mit
142,5 Metern nur knapp Karl Geiger wurde
guter vierter Andreas Wellinger Sechster
das Jahr endet mit dem Abschied von
einer Ikone des Weltfußballs einem
jahrhundertsportler
die WM in Katar hatte er vom Krankenbett
aus wohl noch verfolgt sogar eine
tröstende Botschaft an Neymar gesandt
ganz Brasilien bankte um das Leben
seines fußballkönigs den Unsterblichen
wie sie ihn nennen dass man ihn nicht
vergessen möge war auch seinen Wunsch
der wird sich bestimmt erfüllen mit
seinem erfolgen seinem Leben und seinem
unvergleichlichen Spiel ist er ja längst
in die Geschichtsbücher eingegangen er
starb heute 82-jährig garretbarband
erinnert an Pelé
der König des Fußballs hat das Spielfeld
endgültig verlassen mit 82 Jahren ist
Brasiliens Fußballlegende Pelé
verstorben seine Tochter gab den Toten
mit intimem Blick ans Krankenbett
bekannt auf Pelés offiziellem Account
stand zusätzlich Inspiration und Liebe
kennzeichneten die Reise von König Pelé
der heute friedlich eingeschlafen ist er
war einfach ein großer und das sind
vielerlei Hinsicht
2006 Auftritt in der ZDF WM-Arena der
vermeintlich beste Fußballer der
Historie beweist auch als Experte seine
Vorausahnung ich habe sofort gesagt lahm
kann die Entdeckung der WM werden stimmt
und jetzt reden
diesen Mann umgab eine Aura ed
sornaranstonassi Mentor genannt Pelé ein
Popstar der Fußballwelt
1969 im legendären Maracana in Rio ein
ganz besonderer Moment Pelé erzählte
sein tausendstes Tor das Spiel musste
der Begeisterung wegen unterbrochen
werden
schon im Alter von 17 Jahren ging sein
Stern auf Fußball-WM 1958 in Schweden
der jüngste Spieler schoss Brasilien mit
sechs Toren zum ersten WM-Titel die
Bilder des weinenden Wunder Stürmers
gingen um den Erdball in seinem
Heimatland war er fortan orey der König
trotz lukrativer Angebote blieb er immer
seinem Club treu 18 Jahre spielte Pelé
für den FC Santos ein Genie beifußig
schnell und kopfballstark vor allem aber
spielte er intuitiv
sein berühmtestes Tor das 1:0 im Finale
1970 gegen Italien für Pele der dritte
WM Triumph von windigen Beratern um
seine Einnahmen betrogen folgte er dann
doch noch dem großen Geld zu Kosmos New
York
Kosmos kennengelernt er war für mich der
beste Spieler in diesem Jahrhundert und
ein großartiger Mensch ich bin froh und
glücklich mit ihm ein Jahr in einer
Mannschaft gespielt zu haben die
fifa-ehrte ihn als Weltfußballer des 20
Jahrhunderts engagierte sich in
zahlreichen sozialen Projekten und war
drei Jahre lang Sportminister Brasiliens
zuletzt hatte sich sein
Gesundheitszustand nach einer
Krebserkrankung rapide verschlechtert
bis zu seinem heutigen Tod die Sportwelt
reagierte umgehend Neymar betonte vor
peleva Fußball nur Sport er hat alles
verändert auch Cristiano Ronaldo würde
ich dir ihn er wird ewig in jedem
einzelnen von uns Fußball Liebhabern
Leben wahre Worte die ewig nachhallen
werden über den König des Spiels
[Musik]
das war es von uns im heute-journal
gleich erwartet Sie noch etwas für die
Seele zum Jahresausklang das Festkonzert
aus der Dresdner Semperoper und gegen 23
Uhr gibt es dann unser heute-journal
Update mit Nazan gackdemir bis morgen
auf Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend südlich der Donau ist der
Regen noch gar nicht ganz abgezogen da
kommt schon das nächste Tief hier mit
dem Ärmelkanal hinterher und das bringt
wieder viel Wind mit heute Nacht also
regnet es zunächst noch in
Süddeutschland und auch in
Norddeutschland gibt es noch einige
Regenschauer der Winter hat etwas
nachgelassen und an der Nordseeküste
kommt der aus West südwestlichen
Richtungen die Temperaturen sinken auf 7
Grad am Oberrhein und bis ein Grad hier
im östlichen Bayern und sie liegen
morgen zwischen 7 Grad an der Ostsee und
in den östlichen Mittelgebirge und 14
Grad am Rhein der Tag beginnt erstmal
freundlich sondern Wolken wechseln sich
ab aber spätestens ab dem Mittagsstunden
für dichten sich die Wolken im Westen
das beginnt kräftig zu regnen und der
Wind nimmt auch wieder zu und dieser
auffrischende beschäftigt uns dann auch
noch am Silvestertag schauen Sie dass da
schon gleich wieder das nächste Tief
herankommt das zieht über Großbritannien
sehr schnell weiter über Dänemark bis
nach Schweden und es bringt extrem
vermittelnde Temperaturen mit in der
Nacht zu neue erwarten wir Tiefstwerte
von 10 bis 15 Grad und der Silvestertag
könnte mit Rekordtemperaturen von bis zu
20 Grad am Oberrhein aufwarten in
Norddeutschland ist es dagegen sehr
windig und stürmisch und das ändert sich
am Neujahrstag etwas da wird es nicht
mehr ganz so windig sein es geht ähnlich
mild weiter und auch am Montag sinken
die Temperaturen nur wenig ich wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend